what my geek give me enough time and
pretty much any movie I can read
whatever themes into it I want so this
is something that's a little bit of an
experiment for me and a little bit of an
exercise as well I'm gonna offer
transgender themed readings of five
films well-known films now before I get
into this despite a little bit click
baby nature of the title I am NOT going
to be saying that these films are
designed with transgender themes in mind
what the point of this is is to give you
an idea of how the themes and the
features of various films and stories
can have appeal to somebody who is
looking for transgender themes to be
able to relate to so usually some sort
of transgender audience now again this
doesn't mean that the filmmakers
necessarily had it in mind it doesn't
mean that it was intentional but that is
the nature of giving something a reading
that's the nature of a feminist reading
a Marxist reading a capitalist reading
whatever lens you want to view a film
through you can find themes that will in
some way factor into the lens that
you're going through and I'm gonna put a
trans lens on these five films and to
sort of make it go as cleanly as
possible I'm gonna talk about initially
some of the common threads you're gonna
see recurring and then we'll start to
put it into practice now sort of the
main thing you're gonna be coming across
whenever you or whenever I am going to
be talking about having spotted
transgender or transgender applicable
themes in these films is that there's
going to be a lot of sense of
dissatisfaction from the characters in
question that we're talking about now
dissatisfied characters are actually
incredibly common in not just film but
basically any story because if your lead
character wasn't in some way
dissatisfied then they don't have as
much reason to go on an adventure to
changed you know to have an arc as a
character so dissatisfaction with life
circumstances things like that
incredibly common what is a little bit
less common and what's going to come up
in most of these examples is a
dissatisfaction with self so it's not
just say Luke Skywalker bemoaning the
fact that he's stuck on a moisture farm
and he'd rather be off doing something
else that's a dissatisfaction with
circumstance with location with life in
general but not with himself he doesn't
think there's something wrong with him
there's just something wrong with his
life and where he's stuck so with that
in mind we're actually gonna start with
a film that while the filmmakers I don't
think have ever gone on record as these
being transgender themes it's pretty
well agreed at this point that they are
actually intended in the film so let's
start with the matrix as I would hope
folks would know at this point but you
know what best to not presume the which
house keys were at the time the film was
originally released credited as the
Wachowski brothers so they're not called
that anymore because both Lily and Lana
Wachowski are transgender women the more
that we have found out about the which
house keys and we honestly don't know a
ton about them they're both very private
however knowing now that both of these
individuals are trans women and were at
the very least questioning if we're not
already aware of this fact at the time
that they made the matrix you can see
where what I'm about to talk about
definitely applies so let's talk about
knio knio at a fundamental level feels
that the world is wrong and his place in
it doesn't seem to exist so this is a
combination of something's wrong in the
world but also something's wrong with me
I don't fit here I don't belong here and
yet at the same time he can't pinpoint
why he knows something's wrong he
doesn't know what it is he doesn't know
why it's wrong and that's actually
pretty common
uh-huh as a transgender experience and
then he starts to find people of a
similar mindset through the internet
which it's true now but honestly the
internet did a lot to open up and enable
people like trans people or lgbtq+
people in general or all kinds of people
who fit into relatively small niches to
find each other because he couldn't
count on there being someone else like
you in the town you lived in but you
could find them online which neo does
and lest we forget one of the main
things that the villain Agent Smith does
to mock taunt and torment neo is to dead
named him repeatedly across the whole
thing and what is Neos biggest moment of
triumph
[Music]
he finds his identity he soon hatches
him into the freakin ceiling and again
the more we've learned about Lillian
lana wachowski the more it is very clear
how strong these themes are in the
matrix so let's move on to a couple of
films where it's less likely that the
themes were there intentionally from the
start but they still can be seen there I
want to talk about Disney's The Little
Mermaid which again I have no doubt was
not intended to have transgender reading
but it absolutely works as one it's not
just that Ariel goes through a
transformation from a mermaid to a human
that in and of itself doesn't make it
function as a trans narrative what makes
it function as a trans narrative is her
dissatisfaction with the life she has
her wishing and feeling more connection
to this other world that everything
about her life and what she was born
into says you can't have that you can't
be that feeling that connection so
strongly in the level of sacrifice she's
willing to do in order to experience
being in that world right down to
smaller details like the awkwardness of
bodily changes from her transition from
mermaid into human and I know some
people will say well she did it for a
guy and Eric was the catalyst but go
back and watch that movie again her song
part of your world is about wanting to
be there it's not about Eric before she
meets him she wants to be there she
wants to be among them she feels a
kinship to them Eric's the catalyst that
he's basically the straw that broke
channel
back he's not the reason she does it she
already wanted that Little Mermaid
brings in which is very common
experience for trans people a familial
rejection her father rejects her for
identifying as something other than what
he knows her as what she was born as and
eventually comes around to that which
gives it another layer of beauty right
there so I'm gonna these next few are
gonna get a little bit stretch here but
I had fun thinking about these uh how
about avatar
it's getting sequels people remember
that so somewhat similarly to the matrix
you have the main character in Avatar
finding a place where he has he has
somewhere to be he has a place in this
other world where he fits when he gets
into his avatar and he starts to be with
the Navi he feels much more accepted he
feels much more like this fits than he
did before now a little bit unlike neo
he wasn't necessarily looking for a
meaning or something else
because the world must be wrong he had
just kind of given up and he didn't
assume that there was anything else out
there for neo was looking for meaning he
isn't looking but he finds it anyway and
this can happen for trans people because
some of us don't always know that
identifying differently will help it
doesn't occur to us either because we
just have no reason to think that it
would help we have no reason to try that
and he doesn't seek this out he's
recruited because he happens to fit the
template that they already had because
he had a twin brother who was involved
in this project it's sure coincidence
but then when he's there when he's in a
new body when he's in this city when
he's having this experience every day
he's there every day he is living this
new existence it feels more real and it
feels truer to who he is then every time
he has to go back to the point that he
eventually fully sheds his old life in
his old body and embraces a new one and
if you're going to do a transgender
reading it is actually worth noting in
Avatar that the shift between these two
modes of life when he is still trying to
be both those shifts are awkward for him
and you can tell they're a little bit
uncomfortable and eventually it just it
becomes a chore to go back also not
uncommon among trans people especially
those who take longer to find that
identity and actually attempt to live it
because another thing that can happen is
a lot of trans people will fight that
desire even after they've identified it
but then once they try it they go back
and they go back and they go back until
that's where they decide to stay much
like the main character in Avatar does
this woman I gave up with this one on a
whim but I'm gonna have fun with it so
let's talk about Batman
oh yeah sure this is gonna piss off
anyone that I couldn't make the claim
that Batman functions as a transgender
narrative I am however gonna be very
specific I wanna talk about Batman
Begins because in that film the way in
which we see the journey from Bruce
Wayne to Batman has some parallels and
some function and some utility as a
allegorically trans story I mean first
of all at its core it's a journey of
self-discovery and it it's one that
takes him some time as it does many of
us but that's just a starting point
that's pretty basic and you could apply
that to a lot of things so what else if
I got to go with this particular film
what I find interesting is that Bruce
Wayne's lowest point he hits bottom at
the point of which he is clinging
desperately to a life that doesn't work
for him anymore and hasn't for a while
his lowest point is when he is prepared
and goes with the intent of shooting Joe
Chill that's how low he has become that
is how much the life he was born into
isn't working for him he has tried to
live it he has gone to the schools he's
supposed to go to he has come back to
try and honor his parents but it's not
working
keeps trying to make this fit he's
trying to live the life he's supposed to
lead and it doesn't work he bottoms out
so hard that he almost takes another
human beings life and it's only when he
walks away from that that he starts to
find out who he really is and this could
even work specifically as a closeted
trans narrative someone who isn't out
yet because there's the whole notion of
what's the mask what's the face I have
to present and Who am I really
and for many trans people be it early in
transition or even late into it
depending on life circumstances or
things of that nature a lot of us have
to present the face that is expected
even though it's not at all accurate and
it's not the face that we are feeling
more at home with and that we have been
discovering and developing like how
Bruce Wayne has to present as the
Playboy even though he is feeling more
akin to Batman the more time he spends
in that and that is the side of his life
he's been developing but that's not what
he can present to the world so we're
gonna wrap up because lest you think
that only positive stories
be read with a transgender lens no let's
uh let's end on a horror movie how about
the fly now this one if you're gonna
look at it through a trans lens it
functions a little bit differently
because unlike pretty much every other
one that we've dealt with this is
initially an involuntary change so that
does put it in a bit of a unique sphere
to look at it through this lens and with
this perspective because it is actually
kind of important that all the other
characters I've talked about chose to
explore this other life chose to change
themselves chose to inhabit different
bodies or to alter their own or to
embrace a whole new life or a whole new
identity becoming brundlefly he didn't
choose to do that but once he identified
that that was what was happening he
embraces it and while in the context of
the film it is completely a horrible
accident by circumstance one could argue
that trans people also don't choose they
don't choose their identity at the very
least now if they're going to undergo
severe personal physical alterations
that's usually a choice but that fact
that they have that identity that they
are trans because what you're trans
whether you have surgery or not you're
trans whether you're on hormones or not
so the idea that brundlefly is created
by something that is involuntary
actually doesn't completely derail it as
a trans story and what's interesting
about this one is as he becomes to the
eyes of the world into the eyes of the
audience more and more monstrous less
and less human he is
largely embracing this he is he is
documenting it he is keeping track of it
he doesn't seem to be horrified by it or
at least not nearly as much as one would
think he should be and this entire
shifting sense of self is at first
confusing but he does for the most part
seem to come to certain amount of peace
with it I also like that the change is
gradual most of the other ones we've
talked about have had pretty clear
divergent points where the change
happened here the initial point is
pretty quick but the actual change is
gradual over time which is also going to
be true of most trans people we don't
just go away and suddenly show up again
having had a ton of surgery and all this
stuff no it's a very gradual thing you
can go back and look at my videos from a
couple years ago or go back one year
then go back to you know it happens over
time now
I'm sure someone will bring up the fact
that at the very end he puts his head in
front of a shotgun and seems to want to
end his life doesn't that go against my
his saying that he had seemed to come to
some kind of acceptance of himself I'm
not sure it does because he is
conflicted and so are many trans people
and especially in situations where it
gets hammered home that the rest of the
world is not going to accept us it can
put us in very low places
and for some that can lead to the
thought that I want to die hate to end
on a Saturday or dour note but this life
trans gender-fluid non-binary the whole
spectrum it can be tough and it's not
always sunshine and roses and sometimes
the reading that you can place a film
that and have it function as a trans
narrative isn't going to be a fun
but I still had fun doing this as a bit
of an exercise for myself in sort of and
to a certain degree projecting a trans
lens on some films did people enjoy this
around or were you confused as to what
the hell I was even doing I don't know
this it's a little bit of a weird one
for me but I hope you liked it whatever
your thoughts aren't drop something down
the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch stuff to do like subscribe I
have a patreon share this around all
that stuff but also you don't have to
because end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]